Didier vient de lancer un nouveau
stabilisateur pour vos boîtiers c'est le
RS3 mini il faut évoluer leur gamme et
le reste trois mini il est vachement
intéressant pourquoi parce qu'il est
léger il fait 795 g Le RS3 mini il est
juste là c'est coco qui est dans les
mains coucou coco donc c'est un reste
trois mini il est super cool pourquoi et
bien parce que il fait la promesse pour
le créateur d'emmener un gimbal beaucoup
plus petit pour leur boîtier ça évite
d'avoir des gros game ball donc
aujourd'hui on va venir regarder ce
restaurant ministre qui fait ce qui
promet quels sont les promesses est-ce
qu'il les tient on va venir le mettre en
face du Ronin SC pour regarder un peu la
différence de taille de volume voir si
c'est intéressant voilà tous les points
de ce restaurant mini c'est une grande
présentation générale et c'est surtout
aujourd'hui une vidéo qui a réalisé en
partenariat avec dji qui m'a dit tiens
au bon monsieur gros est-ce que tu
voudrais pas venir tester prendre en ma
découvrir ce RS3 mini de les tournevis
sur ta chaîne c'est justement ce qu'on
fait tout de suite
[Musique]
première question à se poser c'est quel
boîtier vous avez si vous êtes intéressé
par le RS3 mini et si vous regardez
cette vidéo si potentiellement que vous
êtes un créateur de contenu sans quoi
vous allez pas forcément venir vous
intéresser donc la première chose c'est
quelle boîtier vous avez et qu'est-ce
que vous allez venir en faire je vous
invite à aller jeter un coup d'oeil sur
le site de dji je vous mets tous les
liens en bas dans la description parce
que vous allez voir la liste des
boîtiers qui sont compatibles avec le S3
mini tout de suite on est en train de
filmer avec un FX3 de Sony il est déjà
un peu fat mais il tient très bien
dessus absolument aucun problème je
garde la référence de Sony ou aller sur
le à C3 à cet S3 chez Panasonic vous
avez le gh6 GH5 j'ai H4 je vois pas ses
compagnie bref vous avez une liste très
complète allez jeter un coup d'oeil
directement sur le site de dji en fait
le reste 3 mini les 50% plus petit que
son grand frère le RS3 pro et une
capacité de charge jusqu'à 2 kg boîtier
objectif inclus en fait le reste 3 midi
il a une fonctionnalité qui est
intéressante qui a pas ici notamment le
Rona SC que je vous présente qui est un
peu plus grand je voulais mettre à côté
et vous verrez très bien ce que ça dit
c'est qu'en fait il pouvait venir
piloter ici en Bluetooth pourquoi c'est
intéressant parce qu'en fait vous avez
un bouton REC vous appuyez dessus pour
vous lancer directement le boîtier sans
fil en Bluetooth directement ça c'est
mais ça ne serait pas là puisque le truc
est aussi vachement bien c'est que vous
pouvez venir grâce à une petite molette
qui est située devant et bien venir
zoomer par exemple venir moduler les iso
venir changer l'obturateur venir faire
pas mal de choses modifier l'ouverture
donc ça c'est vachement cool on peut pas
le faire ici directement en Bluetooth
avec son Ronin C c'est absolument pas
possible mais vous pouvez le faire ici
directement avec le RS3 mini le seul
truc qu'il faut vous vérifier c'est que
votre caméra vous permet d'avoir toutes
les fonctionnalités avec le bluetooth
ici typiquement avec le FX3 qu'on va
retrouver là c'est pas possible donc
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait on a branché un
petit câble ici en sortie de boîtier en
usb-c qu'on a branché ici directement
dans le RS3 mini ça nous permet d'avoir
toutes les fonctionnalités que j'aurais
pas sinon alors en Bluetooth je pourrais
faire des choses mais je pourrais pas
tout faire une fois de plus aller voir
par rapport à votre matériel voir s'il
est compatible et si vous avez toutes
les fonctionnalités en Bluetooth oui ou
non et le truc à installer ici DJ qui
est vachement intéressant c'est une
stabilisation de 3e génération ça permet
d'aller plus loin notamment par rapport
au Rona essai et ça c'est vachement bien
parce que c'est ce que vous retrouvez
également dans le ronin S3 pro
[Musique]
et on peut également venir filmer au
format vertical alors regardez ce qui
est vachement bien il y a cette petite
partie là que je viens ôter et ça me
permet de le passer très facilement en
format vertical alors pour le pinceau
format vertical il faut que je vienne
rééquilibrer système mais ça se fait
bien alors après une fois de plus si
vous êtes en filaire vous venez vous
brancher là moi je me suis branché juste
en dessous ici ça marche bien et ça pour
venir se balader venir s'amuser et venir
le prendre comme ça pour venir vloguer
très facilement je peux le faire c'est
marrant comme ça je suis en forme
invertical je suis en informatique que
je veux c'est cool c'est pratique et ça
ça me plaît bien et vous avez en plus un
écran tactile couleur qui est situé
juste ici avec pas mal de paramètres
vous allez pouvoir tout piloter on prend
un écran de 1,4 pouces à l'avant alors
totalement tactile pratique alors là je
vous le pose comme ça c'est à dire que
je vous pose son boîtier donc il aime
pas trop il fait un peu la gueule mais
normalement vous lorsque vous l'aurez
comme ça et bien il sera tout vert ici
et on va retrouver le niveau de batterie
on va retrouver le mode là je suis en
mode M1 et vous allez pouvoir venir
naviguer très facilement vous venez
comme ça vous descendez du hop là vers
le bas vous avez nouveaux paramètres
pour venir verrouiller l'écran vous
connecter en Bluetooth directement ici
ça c'est très très facile également le
volume sonore et puis ici les différents
paramètres désactivez le mode selfie
suivi orbite le mode Pouge bref vous
avez quelques petits paramètres
verrouillage automatique de la nacelle
étalonnage horizontal la langue vous
pouvez regarder votre firmware ça c'est
vachement bien ça marche très bien et
sur le bas vous continuez vous avez
d'autres menus vous voyez qui viennent
défiler ici avec la vitesse du joystick
la fluidité du joystick également la
fonction de la molette vitesse de la
molette parce qu'en fait vous avez une
molette derrière on va retrouver juste
en dessous ici un petit joystick qui
vous servira à faire bouger votre gimbal
à déplacer votre caméra directement le
holba droite et gauche le bouton m pour
venir changer de mode M1 M2 M3 vous avez
trois modes ici ok ça marche très bien
le bouton pour venir enregistrer vous
enregistrez vous arrêtez
l'enregistrement vous faites un appui
long vous allez bien faire une photo bon
le truc est très très bien très simple
et hyper intuitif et puis bouton pour
venir l'allumer pour éteindre se situe
juste ici la recharge se fait ici en
usb-c et vous avez en plus une petite
molette ici qui vous permet de contrôler
directement votre boîtier soit en
filaire soit en Bluetooth cette molette
se situe juste ici regardez là alors là
vous avez de l'autre côté quand vous le
prenez en main comme ça regardez vous
avez donc votre écran qui situe là et
toute la partie avec la molette et la
gâchette qui sont là vous appuyez deux
fois sur la gâchette alors mettre le
boîtier en place trois fois vous passez
en mode selfie et la fameuse molette que
vous avez là elle est vachement pratique
pourquoi et bien regardez vous venez
dans vos paramètres ici vous allez avoir
différentes fonctions pas de poignées à
la customiser l'utiliser comme vous
voulez ça c'est très très bien mise au
point et zoom alors moi ici comme j'ai
un FX3 et que j'ai pas un objectif dédié
pour le FX3 ça va pas fonctionner mais
si vous avez un objectif dédié ça
fonctionnera ça vous fera le zoom
directement là moi je l'ai utilisé pour
les ISO on peut également utiliser pour
l'ouverture ça c'est vachement pratique
l'obtirateur et puis ensuite différents
mouvements au niveau de votre game ball
le roux Lille panoramique et en fait
c'est vachement bien parce que vous
pouvez venir piloter directement comme
ça et ajouter des fonctions qui vous
serviront par exemple si vous voulez
venir le monter directement le baisser
non pas en utilisant le joystick parce
que c'est pas forcément très pratique
d'attraper le joystick comme ça faut
venir baisser sa main vous utilisez
directement la petite molette ça vous
fera raccourci donc ça va dépendre une
fois plus de vous de vos usages ça va
dépendre à ce moment-là de quoi vous
allez avoir besoin sur votre tournage
mais je la trouve extrêmement pratique
et vous retrouver un petit support que
vous allez faire mettre sur votre
boîtier à l'arrière qui est très très
pratique alors je vous explique en fait
vous posez votre boîtier le support il
vient se visser compatible Arca ça c'est
vachement cool et vous avez ce petit
espèce de petit relief légèrement
incurvé on va l'appeler le bitonio vous
avez donc le bitoniola sur le FX3 le
bitonio je le mets à l'avant au niveau
de l'objectif il vient scaler au niveau
de mon boîtier mais par exemple sur un
GH5 c'est l'inverse je vais devoir le
mettre à l'arrière parce que il va pas
venir en buter jusqu'à l'avance ça a
posé un problème donc je viens de poser
à l'arrière le seul petit bémol que je
vais avoir ici avec le GH5 et bien c'est
que je suis pas fermé mon miroir
correctement à cause de ça après bon une
fois que je tournage est terminé je
l'enlève si vous voulez le laisser à
demeure sur le FX3 pas de souci sur la
CTS 3 ça devrait fonctionner sur un GH5
ça pose un problème
[Musique]
ici l'autonomie est de 10h tu crois
c'est dji qui nous l'annonce pourquoi
est-ce que je vous quantifie pas les 10
heures directement parce que je viens
pas enregistrer pendant 10 heures
non-stop vous prenez vous le recharger
vous êtes parti alors la différence par
rapport à un ronin SCP c'est que sur le
SC vous montez à 11h le temps de charge
est exactement le même vous êtes à 2h30
de charge 10 heures vous êtes peinard si
vous êtes créateur alors après le petit
truc à savoir c'est que ici vous n'avez
pas de batterie vous pouvez venir
changer à la différence du Ronin et
c'est pour venir changer la batterie
très facilement ici c'est pas possible
donc il va falloir prévoir le temps de
charge il va falloir prévoir votre
autonomie et après le recharger pendant
deux heures et demie pour pouvoir
repartir sur la route mais déjà 10
heures comme celle-là vous êtes peinard
et même au combien ça serait un peu en
dessous de 10 heures 9 heures
d'autonomie 8h30 sur un projet avec un
RS3 mini pour moi ça fait le taf il y a
une seule petite limite qu'on vient
retrouver avec ce système de câble
puisque je suis pas connecteur en
Bluetooth que j'ai pas toutes les
fonctionnalités en Bluetooth avec moi
FX3 ça dépend une fois de plus des
boîtiers et bien c'est que ça va me
poser une petite limite vous voyez au
niveau du FX3 pour venir tourner alors
ça dépend une fois de plus des
connectiques de votre métier ici c'est
un peu la petite limite parce que quand
on va faire des travellings où on part
d'en bas et on monte vas-y mon coco on
part dans ma et on monte on se retrouve
avec un écran qui est incurvé mais qu'on
peut pas venir un cure V plus vers le
bas c'est un peu la limite du truc mais
une fois de plus ça va dépendre de votre
boîtier c'est pas le renard qui fait ça
donc OK et si vous avez trois modes pour
venir filmer grâce au bouton m vous
appuyez vous avez M1 M2 M3 alors ça va
dépendre de vous de votre créativité de
ce que vous voulez faire vous allez
pouvoir avoir des choses qui seront un
petit peu plus anguleuses des choses ou
comme là tout de suite je suis au centre
on vient tourner autour de moi au moment
on va finir par avoir la géant tellement
ça tourne bref ça répond à quasiment
toutes les problématiques en termes de
création et créativité je trouve ça
plutôt pas mal plutôt bien fichu après
une fois de plus ça va dépendre de vous
de vos besoins et de vos usages
d'ailleurs il y a notre usage qui est
vachement intéressant c'est fait de se
dire puisque le boîtier est plus léger
est-ce qu'on peut le prendre à la main
et partir se filmer avec en mode vlog je
peux venir l'utiliser très facilement en
mode vlog pour ça j'appuie trois fois
sur la gâchette 1 2 3 et il va venir se
tourner vers moi et là je vais pouvoir
venir me filmer alors le seul truc qui
est un peu relou c'est qu'il faut que je
tourne ça pour venir me regarder enfin
il faut que j'anticipe voilà une fois
que je suis comme ça je me vois
maintenant pour autant est-ce que je
peux venir vloguer avec alors c'est la
question est-ce que je peux venir le
logo est-ce que c'est un sens au bout
d'un moment autre clairement alors je
savais pas de la musculature de chacun
un voyage j'ai pas des énormes muscles
donc je peux venir le prendre comme ça
je vous cache pas que ça tire un peu il
faudrait que je me rapproche comme ça en
mettant en plus grand angle ultra
grand-angle auquel cas ça irait mais ce
qui est cool c'est que comme on laisse
un truc qui est hyper stabilisé et bien
j'ai quand même balader je peux lui
parler directement dans la tronche et je
suis peinard donc quel que soit les
choses qui vont se passer et bien ça
m'apporte un confort au niveau de la
stable je peux dire m'amuser je peux
venir monter sur un manche je peux venir
faire plein de choses vous voyez hop là
ça je garde un truc qui est tout le
temps hyper stabilisé hyper smooth donc
oui je peux venir vloguer est-ce que
maintenant je vais le faire longtemps en
ce qui me concerne la réponse est non
maintenant il y a un autre sujet qui est
intéressant ici c'est l'accès au bouton
est-ce que c'est pratique vous voyez là
je le tiendrai dans la main donc là j'ai
un vrai grip au niveau de ma main ça
c'est bien j'ai bien accès à ma molette
j'ai bien accès à ma gâchette derrière
également par contre si je veux venir
enregistrer et couper l'enregistrement
soit je vais faire avec la l'autre main
et là je peux le faire appuyer très
facilement sinon il faut que je vienne
là que j'appuie c'est pas hyper pratique
et surtout quand on sait que le joystick
on veut bien le prendre comme ça et
piloter ça me fait perdre un peu de
force au niveau de mon bras donc
j'aurais plus tendance à venir à demain
tenir comme ça là et venir le piloter de
l'autre côté alors après une fois de
plus ça reste une question d'habitude
voir si pour vous c'est pratique ou non
je trouve ça toujours très pratique mais
je trouve ça peut être plus pratique
pour un opérateur quelqu'un qui vient
vlogger directement parce que il faut
peut-être baisser un petit peu sa main
pour avoir plus de flexibilité pour
rejoindre le bouton vous voyez ici que
si vous l'avez comme ça directement dans
la main la place pour le pouce vous
l'avez pas c'est plus compliqué donc je
viens choper un peu plus bas quitte à
coincé un peu la paume de ma main ici
vous voyez et là je peux venir le
manipuler plus facilement et là voilà
j'ai accès aussi ma gâchette et ma
molette derrière bon là comme ça ça fait
le taf il y a une vraie différence de
format entre le RS3 mini et entre le
Rona SC alors c'est la première
génération il y a 2e génération qui est
disponible directement sur le site de
dji mais ce qu'on voit c'est quand même
voyez c'est pas la même taille c'est pas
le même encombrement c'est pas le même
poids là on est à moins d'un kilo là on
est un peu plus d'un kilo bon ça ne sera
pas le même usage le truc que je vais
venir adorer ici sur le SC c'est que
vous allez sentir crampe par cran ce que
vous allez venir l'équilibrer ce que
vous allez venir régler c'est plus
facile ici c'est au juger alors on y
arrive attention très clairement ça se
fait bien il y a un vrai guide on est
pris par la main ça marche bien mais je
trouve que le système du SC est plus
pratique que le RS3 mini à côté de ça le
format il y a rien à dire il y a rien à
voir c'est plus petit c'est plus compact
ça va dépendre vous une fois de plus de
vos besoins le RS c'est pour ceux qui
veulent en produits compact très compact
extrêmement compact avec un boîtier qui
va pas être trop lourd et certains
boîtiers qu'on pourra pas mettre dessus
mais pour autant voyez le format il est
vraiment tout petit et si vous enlevez
en plus cette toute petite partie en bas
qui vous sert de trépied vous allez
encore gagner au niveau de la taille
donc une fois de plus le plus important
ici c'est de venir connaitre vos besoins
savoir ce qui vous tente si vous avez un
ronin et c'est peut-être ça vaut le coup
de venir passer directement sur RS3 mini
mais il y a aussi le Rona SC2 qui est
disponible sur le site de dji à vous de
voir une fois de plus en fonction de vos
besoins il y a juste un petit défaut un
petit truc c'est qu'en fait regardez
venez voir ici ici vous avez le petit
système qui vient loquer la position ici
on le règle et le truc qui est des fois
un peu relou c'est que lorsque je
descends comme ça vous voyez que je
tourne mon écran pour voir et que je
suis comme ça et que je remonte alors ça
dépend des positions et bien des fois
vous voyez il vient flirter là ils
viennent toucher l'écran donc ça c'est
des fois la seule petite position qui
est un peu relou pour faire gaffe parce
que si vous en mettez un coup vous
risquez un peu d'abîmer votre écran donc
à manier avec précaution la deuxième
truc qui peut être un peu relou c'est
que quand il remonte comme ça
effectivement que je suis descendu et
bien que j'ai mes câbles en fait ici
bien mes câbles ils peuvent venir se
choper là dedans alors une fois de plus
de la position donc ça ça peut venir un
peu se mettre là donc en fait il faut
veiller parce que ces systèmes là ils
sont très bien ça permet d'avoir un
système un peu moins cher je pense du
point de vue dji pour venir loquet mais
vous avez un risque de venir choper des
câbles ici si vous mettez un dji Mike
qui est super d'ailleurs j'en ai déjà
parlé en vidéo les voir et ici
éventuellement de frotter l'écran donc
bon c'est le petit point de détail c'est
le petit bémol il faut faire attention
c'est pas forcément grave mais faites
gaffe parce qu'en fonction des plans que
vous allez faire vous risquez d'avoir la
surprise quand même
[Musique]
et vous pouvez également venir piloter
directement votre RS3 mini depuis votre
application cette application elle est
vachement bien elle vous sert à piloter
ici tous vos Ronin de dji alors vous
venez vous l'installer vous la paierez
très très facilement c'est extrêmement
simple ça c'est très très cool et vous
avez plein de petites fonctionnalités la
première c'est de venir mettre à jour
les firmware c'est la première chose à
faire lorsque vous venez acheter votre
Ronin et puis ensuite regarder vous
allez pouvoir venir créer alors ça c'est
pas mal parce que vous avez différents
modes de prise de vue donc il vous le
marque ici prise de vue de pouvoir venir
moduler directement ici y avoir un petit
joystick sur le bol qui j numérique
enregistrée si ça ça c'est bien si vous
êtes à distance et que vous posez votre
nom vous pouvez venir vous voir
directement ce qui se passe ici donc ça
c'est très très cool passez du mode
vidéo au mode photo également donc le
piloter à distance et une fois de plus
ça c'est très bien de le faire comme ça
vous avez plein de petits modules vous
pouvez faire un timelapse un mode
poursuite utilisez également une manette
de jeu pour venir à piloter votre Ronin
vous êtes complètement la personnaliser
donc ça va dépendre une fois de plus des
usages que vous en avez mais si par
exemple vous l'attachez moi j'ai déjà vu
un usage comme ça vous revenez le poser
sur une voiture attachée sur une bagnole
et le mec à l'intérieur il le pilotait
directement avec sa manette de jeu donc
ça c'est une question d'usage question
d'habitude également vous avez également
le mode poursuite qui coule pourquoi
parce qu'en fait sur votre image vous
allez pouvoir venir dire ok à tel moment
tu parles là tu vas là si et ça vous
mettez jusqu'à 10 points donc vous posez
vos petits points là vous planifiez
votre mouvement en fonction de la scène
que vous allez venir tourner une voie de
plus c'est une petite fonctionnalité qui
est très pratique qu'on va pas forcément
avoir en usage un peu plus standard mais
si vous voulez venir le pousser et avoir
des fonctionnalités en plus lors de
tournage et bien vous pouvez venir le
faire ici et ça une fois de plus c'est
très cool vous avez test d'équilibrage
les paramètres du moteur pour fil
utilisateur le statut bref l'application
est complète elle est bien vraiment pour
venir utiliser à distance et moi je
trouve ça très très cool une fois de
plus ici donc ça c'est très chouette
alors la question est à 389 euros est-ce
qu'il faut venir acheter ce dji RS3 mini
alors je vous vois venir vous allez me
dire bonbon monsieur gros on se parle
ici d'une vidéo sponsorisé donc tu es
payé par des dji c'est vrai vous avez
raison vous l'avez vu et c'est clair je
vous le dis dès le départ alors
maintenant je vous le dire très
clairement pour moi mon avis c'est que
ça dépend ça dépend de vous ici on se
parle d'un outil qui va être plus
semi-pro même si on commence à arriver
pour avoir des rendus professionnels
avec un stabilisateur qui va être léger
si vous voulez vraiment monter en gamme
il y en a énormément chez dji donc pour
commencer à arriver dans la gamme RS3
chez dji le RS3 mini je trouve très
canon je trouve très bien le fait
d'abord cet écran c'est simple c'est
très lisible c'est compréhensible on va
vraiment où on va donc ça je trouve ça
vachement bien ça c'est le premier pas
qui est positif maintenant le truc à
venir voir c'est le savoir-faire du dji
alors je pense que vous connaissez tous
dji dji ça a explosé au niveau des
drones la législation aussi un peu
changé donc le particulier c'est un peu
moins de drone c'est un petit peu plus
compliqué pour autant il continue à
avoir du matériel qu'il développe et
sont les rois au niveau du gimbol donc
ils sont très très bon au niveau des
stabilisateurs des caméras donc ici la
gamme Ronin elle marche bien voilà la
question c'est de savoir dans la gamme
ce dont vous vous avez besoin pour moi
le RS3 mini est très bien pour rentrer
dans la gamelle S3 avec un boîtier qui
n'est pas trop lourd un boîtier qui ira
dessus déjà enfin FX3 voilà c'était 3 ça
commence quand même à être un petit peu
lourd moi l'objectif ici on est dans la
série G j'ai un 25 70 autant vous dire
que ça fait le taf ça tient il y a
absolument aucun problème les différents
modes sont là c'est pratique ça va être
surtout pour vous si vous voulez venir
complètement optimiser vos plans et
avoir une image qui est hyper smooth
alors celui-là je trouve bien il est
hyper canon une fois de plus si
s'adressera un public beaucoup plus
large parce qu'il est plus léger facile
à emmener avec soit pour des créateurs
qui veulent maximiser leur contenu donc
oui si vous êtes intéressé et si vous
voulez acheter un très bon stabilisateur
un tarif un peu plus maîtrisé ça reste
quand même un certain budget mais un peu
plus maîtrisé vous pouvez aller sur ce
RS3 Amélie de dji personnellement on
s'amuse bien avec je vous ai montré il y
a deux trois petites limites il y a des
boîtiers vous avez pas avoir toutes les
fonctionnalités au niveau du Bluetooth
mais vous pouvez le faire au niveau du
câble dji a pensé à tout là-dessus il
est bien il est complet il est pratique
il est compact il est léger donc pour
moi c'est oui un grand oui mais pour moi
et mes usages ça va dépendre des vôtres
on n'a pas tous les mêmes usages donc si
vous un kit un peu plus léger vous
pouvez y aller si votre truc un peu plus
lourd un peu plus pro il y a d'autres
produits chez dji mais dans tous les cas
leur produit les Romains la gamme elle
est juste magnifique d'ailleurs
dites-moi vous ce que vous en pensez
dans les commentaires est-ce que ça
pourrait vous intéresser est-ce que vous
voudriez avoir ce RS3 mini de dji oui
non quoi comment vous marquez tout ça
juste en bas dans les commentaires et
nous on se retrouve très bientôt pour
continuer à parler parce que croyez-moi
croyez-moi là tu ne s'arrêtes pas et ça
c'est vachement bien allez je vous
embrasse à bientôt Ciao
[Musique]